okay is that the cue
all right so good morning so i'm just
going to read this through here
as chair of the house municipal and
county government committee i find that
due to the state of emergency declared
by the governor as a result of the covet
19 pandemic
and in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
pursuant to the executive order 2020-04
this body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no physical
location to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
which was authorized pursuant to the
governor's emergency order
however in accordance with the emergency
order i'm confirming that we
are a providing public access to the
meeting by telephone
with additional access possibilities by
video or other electronic means
we're utilizing zoom for this electronic
meeting
all members of the committee and select
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during the meeting
through this platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in the
meeting by clicking on
the following website address and i say
i will just read it off
https colon backslash
forward slash forward slash zoom dot us
four slash j forward slash nine
four five four six nine six
two two five nine or by dialing one of
the following phone numbers
1-3-1-3
or 1-929-205-6099
b providing public notice of this
meeting
necessary information for accessing the
meeting we previously gave notice to the
public of necessary information for
accessing the meeting
including how to access the meeting
using zoom or telephonically
this information is presented uh printed
in the house calendar
c providing a mechanism for the public
to alert the public body during the
meeting if there are no problems with
the access
if anybody has a problem please call
area code are 271
3600 or email at hcs
at leg dot s-t-a-t-e
dot n-h dot u-s
uh during the meeting if the public is
unable to access the meeting
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
so those who write a b c and d's i want
to introduce the staff that are
participating for us we have christina
dyer
who is meeting host good morning
christina and thank you
um additional staff providing support
are jennifer
jennifer four and joel anderson good
morning to both of you as well
um this meeting this is a public meeting
of the house municipal county government
committee
a copy of the agenda and minutes have
has been posted
on the main page of the general court
website under the heading
remote meetings please note that all
votes
are that are taken during this meeting
shall be done by a roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there
is anyone in the room with you during
this meeting which is required under the
right to know law
so that's by preamble and if
representative josephine are you able to
call the role for us
i'm here i am yes
welcome everybody i have the role here
so we'll call a role for attendance
all right representative tatro
yes all right representative porter
i'm here and there's no one with me oh
that's right say if there's anyone
in you in the room with you uh
okay representative i'm here
and i'm with my plants your plants
excellent representative gilman
i am present and unaccompanied all right
uh i the clerk timothy johnson
am here and i am alone uh representative
meter
representative meter here all right
representative darjee
i'm sorry to interrupt folks please make
sure you're giving your location as well
um not just in your house but where
you're located like what town
yes please okay i am in canaan thank you
and let me go back real quick uh
representative tatro where are you
i'm
hillsborough representative
i'm in dover dovah i almost wrote dovah
representative gilman i am in exeter
home
yeah you had some excitement that made
national news
uh all right now i am in canaan
representative meters meet her here
today
and i don't see him see him okay
representative darjee uh president
milford milford okay
representative maggiore do i see him
hello i'm present i am in
dover and i am in a uh hospital recovery
room so there's lots of people around me
but i think they're ignoring me
oh good and represent mom burkett
i thought i saw her where she saw her
there earlier
she's muted mute yourself there
nope oh hi there you go
hi i'm in bar harbour maine um i'm in a
hotel room
uh at the bar harbor inn and my husband
may come through here
i'm not really sure he's sitting here or
harper how's bar harbor today
well it's a little overcast you know we
have the marine layer
that's in but uh the sun is out i think
it will burn off today
no no complaining from bar harbor
no complaining nope nope all right
davis where are you president where are
you i am present
i am in west lebanon and i am alone
west's lebanon i'm definitely getting
that
uh representative dolan i'm president
i'm in londonderry and i'm alone
president kittridge i am president i'm
alone
in rochester new hampshire good old
rochester
excellent all right representative
mcdonald i saw him on here
he's gotta unmute himself eric can
somebody unmute him he's on the phone
so star six will unmute you
representative mcdonald
i hope he's listening i'll come we'll
come back to him if he pops in star six
will unmute you if you're on a phone
line
uh represent represent perrault
i am present i am alone in rochester
okay in rochester and uh represent
pmonty i do not see
representatives
hello representative josephson
looks like he froze it does look like he
froze so let's see if we can uh
get him to call back in oh there he is
oh yeah maybe
okay uh you froze for a moment are you
there with us
okay we see you now
uh
do we see representative pratt do you
see him on the
pheasant oh there you are all right
i'm president raymond and i'm alone
oh i don't hear anything representative
josephson
there we go
do any network problems it looks frozen
yeah he might need to call back in
oh we've lost video
tim we lost you
oh represent representative josephson
you've been frozen for a while are you
still there
representative josephson
i can hear bits and pieces of people
yeah
i wonder if it would be better if you
turned off your video
okay turning off my video for right now
it's a good idea
okay are you still there
well if there's an argument from rural
broadband
oh wait how's that that seems to be
working we can hear you now
okay that's better all right i i'm right
next to my wi-fi so who knows
um okay so where were we we're on
representative uh
lekkas i'm here at my home in hudson new
hampshire
uh alone at the moment uh my wife uh the
other representative lucas may walk
through
all right
well were you calling my name yes
yep i'm present i'm here in seabrook new
hampshire
and there's no one in the room seabrook
okay we are all set uh is representative
mcdonald was he able to get through we
have not heard him yet
i'm gonna have our tech um support joel
will reach out to him and see if we can
get him on and uh
get through the roll right all right so
uh
i i'd like to join uh the attendance as
well
oh yeah representative carson are you
here and where are you in uh
warner i i'm here on my front porch in
warner
excellent everybody else is with me a
little rusty here
okay the roll is all set and we can
proceed
all right um so good morning everybody
um
this is a work session combination with
an executive session afterwards
we've got two bills to look at today um
that we had originally
voted to recommend for interim study and
today as part of that process
we go back and look at those bills
and say do we recommend them for
for future legislation or not recommend
them for future legislation
um and we'll get into that in just a
little bit a couple of things
um just before we get into those um
i'd like to maybe talk about number one
um we have
i guess we have a few people who decided
um the hundred dollars a year wasn't
worth it
um um i i don't know who i i know i know
representative dart
darjee is is um not um
seeking reelection um
i think we have one representative meter
is not he's not here
is there anybody else who um won't be
joining us
because they decided not to do it
representative meter is not running
again
correct yep i think representative
perrault
she's representative right
so anyway i'd like to thank thank all
three of those for their their their
service on the committee and hope they
they come back and join us in the future
so
clyde this is this is tom i i wanted to
let you know that i just heard from tony
piemonte he has an illness and the
family won't join us
okay all right good enough thank you um
so everybody else um welcome here
um veto day is coming up next wednesday
i believe
um i heard uh in a meeting this morning
that the
calendars will be going out um talking
about um
logistics for the meeting look i believe
they're gonna be sent in the mail as
well
um if you the big things i heard is that
um
parking uh may change for you there's at
least one lot i was
i was told that is not going to be
available to us so check the calendar
and make sure the logistics work for you
also there's an email going out
for those who um for lunch
um and if you don't reserve a lunch the
word was
you won't get a lunch so it's it's um
look in your house email for the um
way to order your lunch anything
else anybody anything else related to
veto day that anybody would like to
talk about at this point
okay um then that being the case
i i think um the other thing does
everybody have
um any questions with utilizing uh
zoom for um
making raising your hand or anything
like that i mean christina could you
maybe just go over a couple basics that
people might want to use during the
meeting
absolutely so folks you'll be able to
mute and unmute yourselves at will
if there is any background noise
we'll help you out with that but
if uh you're looking for the raise hand
button
it's on the panelist the participant
screen at the very bottom
and if it does anybody have any
questions
it looks like everybody's ready to go
all right
so um we have two bills
and what i'd like to maybe propose is
that um
we'll take each bill um in order um
we'll maybe have a as part of the work
discussion um
have a discussion refresh ourselves what
the bill is about maybe talk about a
little bit about
um the what kind of testimony we heard
and when
we have ended that exchange um
i will move into executive session on
that bill and look for a motion of
either
to recommend for future legislation
legislation or not to recommend for
future legislation
we'll take a roll call vote um and we'll
do that with the second bill and then um
we can go home or we are home
all right just to interrupt for a moment
uh representative mcdonald is now
present if we could just finish the role
there i think we'll be ready to move
forward
good morning all right uh representative
mcdonald
you are here i am president and i am in
wolf ball and i'm by myself
and you're a wolfeboro all right thank
you thank you
good deal all right representative
mcdonald any other questions
with the logistics for um just using
zoom from
your phone today
i believe i'm all set thank you though
okay very good
all right so um from work session
perspective um we're going to open
a work session on hb 1199
relative to telephone costs for county
prisoners and just to kick it off
i'll read the um
first part part of the the bill of the
analysis section and then we can open it
up for
discussion um the analysis this bill
requires that the fee charged by the
county department
of corrections for prisoners use of the
telephone service
not exceed the county's costs provide
that service
so we heard this bill i believe on um
january 16th so it's been a a few months
since we've had that discussion
um so i will open it up for
any comments or
questions or discussion i did hear from
representative keynes um saying that
she hopes the committee recommends this
for future legislation
so um
and raise your hand if you'd like to
yeah representative lucas has his hand
up representative lucas lucas
yeah i was interested in this um i spoke
with
representative keynes about it back you
know
earlier and followed up with i think
it's laura montenegro the person who
spoke from the new hampshire department
of corrections
and they have uh an interesting way of
doing the state prison which
might be uh you know could be used maybe
at the uh
for the jails the county jails um
although it would take some work to
figure out
uh you know if there's any issues with
that and then more recently in the last
week or so i spoke with arizona teens
again and she's
interested in following up on that and
trying to make it happen i think the
underlying bill is a good idea
um the question is going to be you know
how did the different counties do it and
could they adopt the state system
are there any problems with it so i
would support moving forward with this
all right uh representative porter
thank you mr chair i i agree with
representative lucas um
i thought this seemed to be a pressing
issue
um i'm i'm not sure how we do this
with um interim study bills saying we
didn't really have a chance to study
these
could we if we moved it forward as
recommended for
future legislation could we say in the
report that
there are some issues that need to be
addressed and that studying this
might be a good idea before filing a
bill
um chris christine is that
it's part of our report can that be
included you can certainly put in any
recommendations that you think could uh
improve uh the bill okay
all right representative abramson
yeah i think this is a good bill um
we've heard a lot of good testimony in
favor of it
and uh i just reread the bill again and
i don't
i don't have any problem with it i'm
actually a big proponent of user fees
paying for public services through user
fees instead of through taxes
and uh one of the kind of uh
principles of paying for things through
user fees is that you
try to keep the cost you know as closely
as possible match uh
the cost of providing the service um
and so i think the bill is as well
written as is
as it can be so i don't think that i'm
not sure that it's even possible
actually go ahead and implement it with
anything else attached to it
okay representative dolan thank you mr
chair
i uh i think of recidivism rates when i
think of this bill and i think that
if we can keep people close to their
families
or closer to their families i think we
we give them a better chance of when
they
get out back into the public that
they're going to stay out and not
and not repeat so i think keep keeping
them
tied to their families uh via telephone
is a is a good
uh is a good technique
okay um i you're reviewing my
recollection was i'm just confirming
that looking through the
meeting minutes was that um laura
montenegro from the depart
new hampshire department of corrections
um talked about what they did the state
level and i believe that was
a really good option for maybe to look
at at the county level and
maybe you know that could be also
included in our
minutes on the from this meeting
recommendation
representative lucas another question
yes um
and that's i i spoke with laura
montenegro
and keynes and i think what what needs
to be looked into and i'm not
saying the commitment should do it and
i'm i'm not going to drive it but i
suggested that
uh representative keane's uh i'll look
into his
what would it take to get the state
system used you know by the counties and
the question there is you know would
there be startup costs
if we mandated a constitutional 28a
violation i mean there are some issues
to look into but i think the state
system is actually pretty clever
um the way it works and they have um
they have these pat like pads
notepad things available they have some
number available for loan
and not only they can be used for phone
calls but the prisoners can
do limited email there's some control on
that and also um
you know purchase movie and videos and
stuff and actually
the way they fund the phone calls is
through that
um through kind of the voluntary use of
these things
and in effect the cost of the phone
calls to the prisoners is almost zero
uh but i don't know what would be
involved in uh making those available in
the counties and startup costs and all
that
so that's i think what needs to be
looked into
but basically i think it's a good idea
mr chair this is laurel davis i'm i'm
having a little trouble finding the
ray's hand
yep no uh i'm sorry oh if you click
on your computer under participants if
you click on that
on then it should show you an option
under everybody's name to raise your
hand
okay thank you yep and i apologize it
seems like there's some logging going on
up the road there's some heavy truck
traffic
if there's noise i apologize for that um
representative kittridge
thank you mr chairman um
i i agree that this sounds like a great
idea
here in stratford county we work pretty
hard at getting our
uh prisoners back into the community and
working
as quickly as possible and it has worked
out pretty well for us
my one concern is will we
need a financial note concerning uh
setting this up in counties that have
not uh
met the uh the
met the requirements of the of the of
the bill
that's my only point okay so future
legislation would have to take that into
consideration
um representative levin uh
good morning mr chair and colleagues
um i'm very interested in people's
comments and i'm
glad that representative likas explained
to us a bit about how it works at the
state because i really
didn't know and um i'm on the
delegation with representative kittridge
and i know that our jail
here works very hard to keep prisoners
in touch with their fam
inmates in touch with their families i
would almost
i i'm on the edge of saying let's keep
this
to almost zero because there are inmates
who don't have income who can't pay for
a phone call
and then there are other inmates who who
do have money
and are provided with some money by
their families and can rent a movie or
rent a video or a game and and that's a
positive thing yet
i'm really thinking about the people who
have
yes it's a cost to the jail i understand
it but i think it's a benefit to the
community
if we keep the
telephone link between inmates and their
families
as cheap inexpensive as possible
um and i know this bill may address it
in some way so that's all i wanted to
say thank you
okay thank you representative stavis
thank you mr chair
um i agree with what everyone has said
so far
my only concern about this bill as it is
written
is that it really leaves it up to the
county
to figure out what the cost is
and i'm i'm just wanting a little bit
more
accountability about that and is is
there some way that we could
um include that maybe in a financial
note or or
in the bill itself as a kind of a
reporting process
okay so so mike just to get back on
track here we're
we're not looking to either amend this
bill or anything like that
what what has to happen at this point in
this legislative session is somebody
else
maybe representative keynes would put
pen
together a new piece of legislation for
the next
for 2021 and resubmit the bill
um so at this point we can we could have
that conversation but we
if we had comments we probably could
include them in a report that we
associate with it but um it will be
brand new legislation
um representative leckas
yeah i suppose i mean that was my
understanding and i told representative
keynes that you know i supported the
idea and if she wanted i wasn't going to
drive it but if she wanted to
uh proceed you know next time i'd i'd be
glad to work with her and maybe sponsor
it and if anybody else has particular
ideas maybe talk with her and
get together and good suggestion
representative gilman
uh yes i'm supportive of uh uh sending
this to
uh on for future legislation and i would
join in representatives uh with some
uh input because we've been having some
incidents and
at the rockingham county jail but they
don't involve long-term
inmates uh so there needs to be some
consideration for
people who are there for a short period
like maybe even just overnight getting a
phone call
because we've had incidences where
people don't get phone calls and they're
released
and have no way to get anywhere or call
anyone
so that would be my thing to consider
while in the new legislation
okay very good i don't see any of their
hands raised does anybody else have
anything they'd like to add
um i don't see anybody
hey hello this is kevin representative
pratt yes i'm looking for my phone i'm
in favor of the program
um i think it should be self-sufficient
all paying for itself
i don't think we should uh fund it it
used to be a program in rockingham and i
know a lot of other county jails where
inmates could earn money by doing
different
jobs around the jail uh if they want to
make a phone call they could
actually do a little work and pay for
the phone call themselves
so i think uh cutting down on the profit
is a good idea
the jail shouldn't make a large profit
on the call but it should be
self-sufficient
okay
that's all i have to say thank you all
right i'm in favor of the bill thank you
all right um anybody else
last call okay representative mcdonald
did you want to add something
i'm off that thing no i'm good thank you
okay
um all right that being the case um
would someone
like to make a motion it can be either
recommend for future legislation or not
to recommend for future legislation
we're going to have to write a blurb i
don't know if there's a
blurb that goes with that representative
did you have your hand raised yes uh
i'll be happy to move this
uh for future legislation and i'll write
a blurb
all right and representative abramson
did you raise your hand yeah i was gonna
move i was gonna make a motion also that
we recommend this for future legislation
would you like to second that
recommendation
are you talking to me yes yes all second
okay so the motion has been made to
recommend for future legislation
by representative seconded by
representative abramson
um representative josephson could you
call the role please
absolutely can everyone hear me okay i
can hear me
all right so the motion on the floor is
to recommend for future legislation on
house bill 1199
representative yes representative porter
yes representative yes
representative gilman yes clerk votes
yes
representative dargi yes representative
maggiore
yes representative mom burkett yes
representative davis yes representative
dolan
yes representative kittridge
he's muted yes all right representative
mcdonald
yes and representative pearl yes
representative pratt yeah
representative lucas yes and
representative davidson
aye all right i have 18 to nothing the
motion carries
oh i guess we'll keep that guy in here
all right regular carson
chair says yes seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen four two fifty
two
all right motion carries uh i just
realized that my daughter is doing her
school online right now so that might be
some of my video problems but all right
so we're all set with that one
with with that i'll close the executive
session on hb
1199. um an open work session on
um hb1305 relative to the consideration
of home share
income and um work session i will read
the analysis
just so everybody gets refreshed on that
this bill exempts income from home share
arrangement from the determination of
net
assets for purposes of determining
eligibility for certain property tax
exemptions
this bill also accepts such income from
public assistance eligibility
determinations
so with that please raise your hand if
you'd like to
comment on the bill and whether we would
be in favor recommending that for future
legislation or not uh starting off
representative porter
you mr chair i do recommend that this go
forward for future legislation
um we worked hard on a bill to help with
affordable housing
uh which is now kind of sitting on
somebody's table
we do have a crisis in this state for
affordable housing
and this is a way to allow
people who are struggling to pay for
their homes and people who are having a
hard time finding a place to live
to join forces and i think it makes
sense um
it would be an easy fix and um i
i would like to see a program like this
go forward
okay thank you representative dorje yes
uh i support moving this forward for
future legislation
i want to bring out two things that came
up
in the previous discussion of it which
should be
considered for the future legislation
one is that the
line two talks about amending rsa 72
7237b
3b uh it really should be 3a
at the end uh it's it's addressing the
wrong section of the rsa
all right and the other one is that
there was comments about not talking
about works here but just saying that
um if you have rent
uh if you have rental income for someone
that's living with you
uh that it not be included as part of
your income uh
the income test for the uh the exemption
so
uh maybe some wording changes uh would
be appropriate
um representative yeah i agree with uh
representative darjee especially on the
latter part there was all kinds of
uh text in there about various things
that are nice ideas but really
you know didn't have any effect and i
don't see any point including that in
statute you know
people helping each other those
arrangements which might be nice but
you know if it's gonna go forward keep
it clean to just uh
you know you know what the real uh um
key is for what effect it would have
good enough um i don't
see any other hands up um i i also
support this bill
um i think it should be go for future
legislation
um i i agree with um
representative porter um affordable
housing is is a real issue and if we can
if people can
um have other folks living with them in
a home
sharing arrangement that is certainly a
good way of moving forward and it
shouldn't count against you if
if you you're still trying to make ends
meet so
um representative porter i'm
representative i
i'm sorry i couldn't i saw your your
your hand up
i couldn't quickly find my ray's hand
button all right so
yes um i agree with everything that
representative darjee said
and others um and i just i think one
point that really has to be
clarified legally is the issue
related to um any rental income
not affecting a person's eligibility for
medicaid
or or services that are related to
i i don't know that if we pass
legislation uh saying that yes it does
that that would necessarily um
pass muster uh
with medicaid um and the feds so
i that that question is the only
question i in my mind that really needs
to be answered
um and the folks from medicaid would be
the people who would
um say uh thumbs up or thumbs down
if that is something that could uh
actually occur
that a person any additional income
would
uh not be counted toward eligibility for
medicaid that that's the question i
i think needs to be answered okay thank
you
representative porter thank you again mr
chairman you're right representative
marmocat i agree on that point
uh one thing i just wanted to bring
forward was the idea that when we were
talking about the um
affordable housing bills that came out
of the governor's task force
one of the incentives that was used to
help
developers move forward with projects
was to give them
a a break on taxes so i don't think
giving
people who are house sharing like this a
break on their taxes is out of
bounds done before with other bills that
are
attempting to address this issue
it's just that it's property taxes we're
talking about here rather than business
taxes
but they are still taxes so
okay um i don't see other any other
hands raised would anybody else like to
add to the conversation before we go
on an executive session on this
representative abramson uh
i'm re-reading the bill a third time
sometimes you read a bill and you get a
different uh
impression of it i think that the the
language of the bill is pretty
clear and straightforward it just says
uh
this is house bill 1305
it's simply adding in language that says
for clarity shall not include income
from a home share arrangement
in which the applicant receives
assistance with housework or other
activities of daily living in exchange
for reduced rent
i don't know anywhere else in federal
tax code or anywhere else
where a discount gets considered as
income or a discount in exchange for
work is ever considered as
as income i have have had housemates in
my house over the years where they
couldn't afford to pay
and they received some kind of discount
on their rent in exchange for doing yard
work or some such thing
and i think currently the
most agencies that i've dealt with have
already said
that doesn't get counted as income when
when people are in such a dire situation
that they they're having such a hard
time work
having such a hard time finding work
outside of the home
that they have to work around the home
around the house or
apartment complex where they live in
exchange for a discount um
i want to i wanted to quote some
irs uh publication that agrees with me
on this but i
it's been several years so i can't
reference it but
discounts are usually not considered um
income as it is
okay thank you representative yeah i
just want to um
refer and uh representative abramson i'm
not sure
what you are specifically referring to
but i'm referring to
roman numeral six that reads any income
from a home share arrangement
in which the applicant receives
assistance with housework or other
activities of daily living in exchange
for reduced rent
shall be excluded from income from
purposes
for purposes of determining eligibility
for public assistance
including medical assistance and food
stamps provided that if eligibility for
the assistance program is governed by
federal guidelines
uh such income shall be disregarded to
the extent
permitted by federal law so
i guess there is a clarifying point
there uh and i understand that it's just
that i think this issue
just needs to be cleared up you know we
don't want to get in the middle of
um eligibility issues and i i just think
it
it just needs further clarification
before it even gets implemented
that's all i was trying to say okay
thank you
um anybody else would like to join the
conversation before we go
make a motion here
representative just to let you know we
do have two folks as attendees anita
burrows and sarah aiken who have their
hand raised at attendees i'm not sure if
you want to recognize them it's um at
your discretion
sure who who are the folks or the type
of people i need
anita burroughs and sarah aiken okay
um sure i will open it up for their
their input
please okay who would you like first um
just take them in the order you read
them that'd be fine okay sure uh here
comes anita burrows
all right okay thank you thank you thank
you for
letting me speak i just want to say that
remarkably i agree with every single
thing that's been said
here on the committee today and um i
really appreciate
your support and i think the um comments
that were made about adjustments in
terms of
of um work sharing and whatnot um are
are significant and um anyway that's all
i wanted to say is thank you
you were one of the prime sponsors for
this bill correct
and would you be resubmitting it again
yes absolutely all right thank you
um yes second person please okay
uh we have sarah aiken
all right good morning good morning
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to share some information with you my
name is sarah akin
and i work for community bridges
community bridges is one of 10 area
agencies that support people with
developmental disabilities and acquired
brain disorders
and i just wanted to say thank you to
the committee um
for taking this so seriously
one of the ways that we support people
with developmental disabilities
in our region and throughout this state
is with something called
enhanced family care and it is a shared
living opportunity for people with
disabilities
to live essentially in a foster care
type situation but it's
for adults and so they share their home
with staff and providers
who assist in their daily living
experience as a result um
the the folks that are um
that are helping to assist with the
person with a disability
receives a stipend um for those services
and um so i would just caution you
i do not know tax law as representative
abramson was talking about he certainly
knows more about it than i do
um but i did want to just echo something
um that had been said previously which
is
whatever you decide to do i would just
caution you
that there may be
folks that you haven't considered like
those
in a home share or enhanced family care
option
um that relies on medicaid in order to
be
able to access their services and so i
just
i just think that it's very very
important
for us to do our due diligence as a
community
to assure that we don't upset
a very well-oiled apple cart
um enhanced family care is one of the
least expensive
and most productive ways that we support
people with disabilities
in our communities so i would just ask
for you to be very cognizant of that
and i would be happy to work
with this committee or with the
representative who put forward this
legislation um to assure that
we don't inadvertently um
harm those with disabilities and i i
appreciate
the opportunity to speak to you today
thank you so much for your work i know
it is
very tricky always but especially during
this time
so thank you thank you very much for
your input
um that being said uh if any other
committee members would like to add to
the conversation before we go into
executive session
was that representative 11 or is that a
hand raise
no all right um okay
so we'll open up the executive session
on hb 1305
um i would look for a motion to either
recommend for future legislation or not
to recommend
for future legislation who would like to
jump in
i'll make a motion that we recommend
this for future legislation
motion i will second representative
abramson
all right um motion to recommend for
future
legislation by representative abramson
seconded by representatives true eleven
all right um i would ask representative
josephson could you call the role please
of course all right so we're here we are
on house bill 1305
uh and the motion on the floor is to
recommend for future legislation
uh yes
representative porter yes
oh
i didn't freeze did i okay right after
representative porter you kind of faded
out
tim who's after representative porter i
was on muting
[Music]
uh i think i am
yes absolutely
yes
represent matt jury yes
all right sorry representative davis
yes representative dolan yes
episode cartridge yes represent
mcdonald's
yeah ribs are prop yes
representative pratt yes
representative yes representative
abramson
hi uh i don't know if you heard me but
clerk votes yes
and then representative carson yes
all right mom burkett
votes yes thank you okay all right i got
everybody 17-0
okay that being the case i'll close the
executive session
um uh christina what what happens um
from here so folks will
um write their statement uh with the
recommendation
um and they can either send it um
to you for um for acknowledgement you
can send it to me
or heather either one is fine okay is
there a deadline
for the reports i don't know that
there's a deadline but sooner than later
i think is is
probably best um i think it's too late
for this
this week but um we see a calendar this
week's calendar but we're still
on every other week calendar basis we're
back to weekly now
we tend to put all the statements in one
calendar so um we'll be working through
the rest of the month
um but as i said probably sooner than
later so it doesn't get lost
okay so if those people writing the
committee reports needed to access the
recording from today is that possible
yes absolutely um it is on the youtube
link that is um it would be in this this
week's calendar
if they needed to go ahead and take a
look at the recording
okay for those people who uh made the
the motion to
future legislation um if we set a target
to having reports in for the next
calendar about within the week was that
doable
yes okay all right so if you can send
them to
um send them to uh
uh heather goalie uh copy myself and
also um
representative joseph and that would be
great
okay all right any other
um committee business anybody to bring
up i'd like to
in that case uh wish everybody a great
day thank you for coming in taking part
of the
your end of summer good to see everybody
and hopefully we'll see everybody um
next week
so bye take care mr chair
yes i just said thank you
oh okay you thank you thank you all
right
have a great day bye